l'air du temps de la mode a vraiment
changé
avant il y avait des impératifs des
dictatures il y avait des couturiers qui
dictaient des choses qu'on ne fait
jamais porter un vêtement à l'envers
c'était pas possible ça n'existait pas
au fond pourquoi pas parfaitement à
l'envers c'est vraiment la liberté du
geste liberté de latitude et c'est
fantastique de pouvoir être enfin
exactement comme on en a envie
sans dire je suis à la mode ou pas ce
qui m'intéresse dans la dans la mode
c'est surtout la femme qui bouge avec
ses ouvertures avec ses déchirures avec
tout ce qu'elle reçoit au jour le jour
et c'est un vêtement de l'intérieur ces
traitements d'aujourd'hui je fais du
coup j'ai fait du long je crois que ça
n'a aucune importance je crois que c'est
surtout un état d'esprit c'est surtout
une expression c'est surtout une envie
je crois que n'importe quelle femme peut
avoir envie d'être longue d'être court
d'être stage de ne pas l'être
je crois que tout est permis tout est
facile maintenant